foreign
[Music]
and Welcome to our session where we'll
talk about how you can lift and
transform vsphere workloads without
disruption featuring broadcom
my name is
engineer with Google cloud and with me I
have Manoj Sharma
who is a director of product management
with Google cloud and ganeshanaki Raman
who is head of platform engineering with
broadcom
today we'll cover why you should choose
GCV what's new with GCV broadcom's
Journey with us
power of partnership call to action and
then conclude with some q a
so let's talk about why should you
choose GCV in the first place
there are several things that are top of
mind for it leaders on one hand are
there ever-present requirements of
optimizing cost enhancing security and
delivering the availability that
applications and businesses need
on the other hand every company is
trying to harness the part of artificial
intelligence and Cloud transformation
let's dive into this further
when we put this in the context of
Enterprises
vsphere Powers the majority of compute
workloads in on-prem environments and
there are 85 million vsphere based
workloads
the challenge this creates
is businesses need to choose between
lift and shift and refactor and
transform every day
on one hand are the business
requirements of enabling growth and
transformation leveraging The Best of
data analytics artificial intelligence
machine learning and security whereas on
the other hand it operators
are trying to optimize cost minimize
risk and downtime and maximize the use
of existing Investments that they have
already made
The Dilemma this creates is how do these
organizations rapidly transform while
minimizing risk change management and
expenses
do they lift and shift today and deal
with the transformation in the future or
do they refactor and transform now
balancing the two often requires certain
trade-offs forcing it leaders to either
choose lift and shift which is low risk
and effort but requires a long time to
enable transformation or refactor and
transform
which enables fast innovation
but requires significant upfront
Investments
this is where Google Cloud VMware engine
comes into play for these Enterprises
we are taking a unique approach when it
comes to providing a cloud-first
experience for vsphere based workloads
in Google Cloud using our first party
offering Google Cloud VMware engine or
gcba
GCV accelerates transformation while
balancing risk and Agility enabling us
to meet our customers where they are
it delivers a dedicated VMware private
Cloud infrastructure in Google Cloud
with vsphere esxi for compute we stand
for shared storage and NSX for software
defined networking
since we are running on vsphere you can
easily migrate your workloads to GCV
without any change or disruption
you can continue to use the migration
tools that you're most familiar with
such as hcx and once you migrate over to
GCV you can integrate easily with other
services to further accelerate your
transformation
let's look at some of the features of
gcbe
GCV is a first party offering similar to
compute engine or any other service in
Google Cloud
it is sold and delivered by Google Cloud
it is also supported by us
with GCV you can quickly provision a vml
private Cloud dedicated to you using
self-service within an R and instantly
take advantage of Auto scaling
you can get capacity on demand or
through terms subscriptions using an
Opex fashion
since the service is delivered by us we
take care of platform deployment
patching monitoring security and
automatic repetition
this frees you from the effort of
managing your own infrastructure so that
you can focus on the workloads that's
critical to you
it also provides integrated billing
unified identities and access controls
that enables easier consumption of
vmware-based workloads
once you migrate your workloads to dcv
you can also quickly integrate with
services like bigquery and Cloud
operations
using private connectivity
furthermore you can extend your
ecosystem of Enterprise applications and
services as you migrate over to Cloud
without any changes
we have partnered with leading isvs to
offer Solutions such as backup disaster
recovery and remote desktop
these partner Solutions include rubric
cohesity and VM
therefore you can continue to use the
Enterprise applications and it tooling
that you need to run your business in
the cloud without making any changes or
disruption
we have also partnered with NetApp to
offer storage solutions for VMware
customers in the cloud
an Enterprise grade platform let's look
at some of the differentiators that we
provide
we provide 99.99 of uptime SLA for
clusters with 5 to 32 nodes and ftt of
two are greater without requiring
stretched clusters this is higher than
any other alternative out there
we also offer dedicated connectivity
with core service functions such as vsan
and vmotion that enables us to provide a
platform that's highly stable and
available
this also allows us to support
Enterprise applications that are highly
available
second deep networking integration with
Native networking functions such as VPC
gcv's networking is built on top of
Google's powerful networking
architecture
with simplified Regional and Global
networking modes you can create a VPC
Subnet in any region where this service
is available
this also allows you to architect Global
networks without the need or overhead of
creating and connecting Regional Network
designs
this is not the case with other Cloud
providers where you have to configure
special networking to connect different
regions for example creating vpns over
wide area network to enable global
communication
the challenge this creates
is it adds to your complexity of both
operations and deployment in addition to
cost
third we offer the largest cluster sizes
with up to 32 nodes and clusters with
our dedicated placement group design
and last but not the least we offer
dedicated 100 gbps of East-West
networking without bandwidth
oversubscription
that's not the case with other
Alternatives that often require
bandwidth over subscription
our GCB nodes also come with redundant
switching
both of these features are especially
important for Enterprise workloads such
as databases that are mission critical
and also latency sensitive applications
such as real-time communication
Google Cloud VMware engine is available
in 18 regions including some new
additions in Milan during Delhi and
Santiago we offered the same phone nines
of uptime SLA for all of these regions
where GCV is available in
some additional regions such as London
Frankfurt Sydney and Virginia we are
offering additional zones to support
customers that require higher levels of
availability
and with this I would like to invite
Manoj Sharma to talk about what's new
with Google Cloud VMware engine
thank you shantini
I am Manoj I lead the VMware engine
product
and I'm here to talk about what's new
with VMware engine and some exciting
developments as well that are in the
works with this product
so our customers have been talking about
you know what really matters to them
they are really focused on reducing cost
of the infrastructure making sure it's a
good fit with the right TCO
but at the same time they want to have
the right skill and advanced
capabilities with automation without
compromising on the Simplicity that
they're that they've come to know and
love in the product
and at the same time they don't want to
compromise on what we all care about
which is security right I mean you want
to make sure you get all the visibility
all the tooling that you need in order
to get the most secure deployments
and then finally it's not just about you
know solving problem a by deploying
infrastructure solving problem B by you
know adding some tools in it and so on
and so forth customers want to solve all
Enterprise needs holistically whether it
comes to availability you know whether
it comes to data protection business
continuity everything should be built in
and not have to you know sort of tool
your way into getting to the right and
and State uh in production and when you
la when you're live and so we are trying
to meet those needs as well and then
finally
um
you know customers come to Google Cloud
to get the best of cloud
and to Avail of all the advances that
are possible in the cloud and what we're
all witnessing is the advances in Ai and
generative Ai and so we'll see get a
sneak peek on what we are doing in that
space uh in order to help VMware
customers
so
let's talk about the first exciting uh
announcement and development that we
have in VMware engine which is the ve2
platform so a current node type was
called ve1 VMware engine 1 and it had a
certain configuration but with HCI as
some of you might be aware of
hyper-converged infrastructure which
includes storage and compute the problem
is it's like a one-size-fit-off fit fits
all approach which means the address is
either going to be loose fitting or it's
going to be tight fitting most of the
time and that doesn't work when it comes
to cost right so what you want to do is
to have a platform that gives you the
flexibility of choosing the right level
of compute and CPU compute and storage
that you want to allocate to your
workload so that you can get the best
TCO and we obviously offer it at
different price points and so what this
helps is if you have a database that
needs a lot of storage then you can
choose the larger storage form factor of
ve2
and if you have vdi which needs a lot of
compute or you might have a memory
intensive workload then you can choose
one with Less storage and once again as
I said you know that gives you a better
fit it comes with the later generation
Intel CPU as well which in our
benchmarking had 50 percent lower
inter-thread communication latency what
that means is your database transactions
runs faster and your vdi interactions
Mouse clicks are that much more snappier
right so I think we're giving you latest
generation infrastructure but also
giving you flexibility of configuration
to choose at the right optimal TCO and
we are releasing the ve2 standard 128
which is one version of the CPU and
storage configuration first and it you
know really
gives you a lot more capacity than we
had before including more than two and a
half times of the memory that you got
with our current node type
now a similar version of that problem is
storage so let's take the example of Dr
where let's say you're trying to
replicate a lot of data you have an
active active Dr from on-prem to the
cloud and you're replicating a lot of
data into the cloud what you need to do
then is to have a lot of storage in your
environment and maybe limited amount of
CPU and you want to keep adding storage
by adding uh you know some some sort of
you know tier two sort of storage
context but how do you do that in HCI
without having to you know Mount
additional external storage which is
also possible well if you want to keep
the HCI form factored the hyper converge
form factor which is to have storage in
the same cluster the high performance
storage that comes with nvme but not
have to pay for compute and so you can
leverage you know really high
performance primary story then it's
possible with the storage only node type
and the the good thing is that we will
be offering this with ve2 as well and it
can save you at least 75 it'll be it
will save you at least 25 percent uh if
not more depending on the type of node
type you you choose in order to meet
your storage needs
so uh
next up is networking and
the analogy I like to make here is
building the house
so what you have to do when you
configure VMware in the cloud
is that you build a house but then you
have to worry about bringing the
plumbing into the house as well right
and you have to actually lay out the
plumbing yourself connect to the cloud
vpcs and then do the interconversion
sometimes you have to set up routers
sometimes you have to configure uh
peering with multiple cloud vpcs and uh
you know all of that's super complicated
and adds to operational overhead and
cost and time to manage and so forth
and this was already much simpler in
gcve you didn't have to do all this sort
of routing configuration and management
yourself but you did have to initialize
the peering
now what we're doing is we are saying
you know what when you make the house
the plumbing comes with it as part of
the uh the consumption so
when you first create a private cloud in
gcve now you will get this peering that
uh goes into the cloud VPC automatically
automatically detected and automatically
configured on your project and we call
this zero config networking and so zero
config networking is the new development
on the networking space that will now be
possible with uh with our next
Generation networking called VMware
engine networking and it's also a very
flexible
pattern and Paradigm for us because it
allows you to configure multiple vpcs in
the same private cloud or a many-to-many
connection from uh from vpcs to your
private clouds or to connect with
external Services partner services such
as IBM NetApp or others or even connect
to projects that are not in the same
organization as yours external projects
so you can have some sort of a partner
based service connected to your VMware
environment so this kind of flexibility
in networking you know when you start
doing Advanced things you need this
flexibility but in a very simple way so
that you're not spending all your time
trying to manage uh you know this mess
of wires of virtual wires but massive
wires of connectivity and we make it
possible and easy with VMware engine
networking
so now I'm going to talk about three
things that address the security aspect
that I talked about right the Securities
Paramount in the cloud
and the first of these is what we call
VPC service control Solutions which
essentially
in VPC service control what is uh what
the the policy you can set is that I
don't want any exfiltration meaning no
outgoing internet connection from my
environment
so that uh you know the environment's
secure I know that there's no external
service being offered
accessed and that's now possible that
that is possible with VPC service
controls in the cloud but but with the
solution it's also now possible on
VMware engine environments as well so
this is the first security measure that
we're releasing the second is visibility
and audit you want to know everything
that's happening in the environment you
want to know who's doing it when it's
happening where it happened what it
changed and it was possible with VMware
vcenter syslogs it was also possible
with NS nsxt syslogs and then the
control plane logs but for the first
time we are now offering ESX log as well
right so ESX is the host operating
system logs and we manage the the host
and the operating system the es6
operating system but
uh we are giving you visibility into
that as well so that you know exactly
what's going on in your environment and
you have total visibility for giving you
the peace of mind that you need in the
cloud
and then the third thing in security is
Access Control now what was possible so
far was an administrative level of
control and then a viewer level of
control in gcve but now what we have
done and this is already released is the
ability to do fine-grained access
control if somebody is managing
networking they get exactly that
configuration if somebody's managing
storage they get the storage management
rights and um and so on and so forth
user management administrator
Administration logging etc etc right so
you can imagine all sorts of roles that
you have in your organization you can
bring those roles through fine-grained
permissions applied to every single
function available in the platform
and we'll be continuing to enhance this
with more and more granularity as time
passes
okay so that covers security now coming
back to Enterprise needs I mentioned hey
when I want to set up something in
production I want all my needs to be
addressed holistically whether it's
about external storage you know it might
be file stores that I'm accessing from
vdi environment or I might have tier 2
storage or I might have Dr protection I
want all of these needs to be addressed
so the first thing in that space is the
external storage with file store and
NetApp both are you know equally
supported options that we are offering
in our platform and that allows you to
address the needs of storage expansion
and storage growth and data protection
that I talked about
but the second area that we are focused
on is to make a
it uh very easy and push button for you
to get data protection and business
continuity for your workloads so we
offer the VMware platform the VMware
platform has an ecosystem a very large
ecosystem of data protection and
business continuity as you all know you
know whether it's veeam or whether it's
zerto or whether it's some EMC solution
and so on and so forth you can sort of
bring all of those as add-on
capabilities and layer it into the
platform and they are fully supported
but
you also in some cases want to use the
provider native capabilities and you
want it to be built in you don't want to
configure you know the tool yourself and
what we're announcing and offering is
the ability to get this data protection
through
gcp native data protection and Backup
Tool which will be now bundled can be
bundled as part of gcve through this
gcve protected
add-on skew and what this does is it
gives you data protection at a fixed
cost so you pay five percent of the
infrastructure cost
and you can use unlimited capabilities
you know back up as many VMS as you want
and the software is going to be
basically working seamlessly uh without
you having to configure and manage
things explicitly you just have to pay
for the storage uh depending on the
amount of data protection you're having
the external storage that that this
service uses it uses GCS to backup your
data so that's what you will be paying
additionally for
all right and so now I'm just gonna
transition but before that uh I want to
talk about something exciting so
who in the audience here has been using
the VMware platform for more than 10
years
so about you know 25 30 I think if not
more
and when you come to Google Cloud you
know you've you've given us the very
important responsibility to manage your
environment and make it available to you
as a service but you know with this
revolution of generative AI happening
around us it's Google's responsibility
to give you all the power and capability
of generative AI to make your life
simpler and better you should be able to
have deep knowledge and insights about
your environment you should be able to
have an understanding of exactly all the
different parameters and options
available to you you should be able to
uh you know generate scripting and
Automation in seamlessly and easily and
I'm happy to mention today that we are
working on this we're not announcing
availability yet but we're working on
this and it'll be uh you know in preview
soon
where you can do all of this and it's a
very special capability and very special
especially for for VMware because it's
it's doing it's giving you something
that's not built into a duet
experience yet which is the ability to
get insights for with your inventory and
this is an extension of the duet
capabilities that you heard today that
were announced today but an application
of that into the VMware space so I'll
stop talking it's better to see the demo
and get a sense yourself of how this
works
okay so what you see first is
deep insights on your inventory and the
way we offer this is privacy preserving
which is that all your inventory
information stays local to your
environment it does not go to the large
language model service that we uh that
that we leverage in the we need the
behind the scenes we are actually
leveraging vertex Ai and you do need to
have access and registration toward xai
in order to use this but it still
preserves privacy by keeping your data
local the second thing you see is deep
insights it gives you you know
information about all aspects of the
stack that you're consuming and uh it's
very knowledgeable about that and the
third thing you'll see is automation you
can generate scripts about your
environment and you know whether it's
power CLI terraform or python-based
scripting it's very knowledgeable about
that and it can save you a lot of time
when it comes to performing Advanced
administrative tasks
so with that I'm gonna pass the bet on
to Ganesh and uh he'll take you through
the
next part
hi everyone my name is Ganesh janakaram
I head platform engineering at.com
a small fact
over uh well over 99 percent of internet
traffic that traverses through
something somewhere broadcom we are
immensely proud about that
we are technology leaders in the
semiconductor and silicon space we're
also leaders in infrastructure software
like
we thrive in Innovation and we have a
panoply of well-differentiated products
in several verticals and we including
Cutting Edge Technologies like
generative AI both on the silicon and
the software side
at the end of the day it's all about
sound financial model the robust
business that drives Diversified and
sustainable Revenue which is really
important to us
so
what does our software portfolio look
like right so from Mainframe to mobile
we power enable
maintain automate Monitor and secure
some of the world's largest most complex
and Mission critical systems for our
customers
we have products both on the on-prem and
on the SAS space primarily go through
acquisitions
on the portfolio side Mainframe is a
very important part of our portfolio The
Who's Who of the world still actively
use Mainframe
we have leadership in several other
areas in the undistibuted side like
valueops with products like rally and
Clarity in the monitoring space with
netops app Neta and AI Ops right but we
have a wide portfolio of security
products covering almost all dimensions
of of security from identity management
to network perimeter security all the
way to securing your your last device we
cover the entire Spectrum in terms of in
terms of solution right
uh we acquired a semantic a few years
back with that we have uh products like
semantic endpoint security that protects
millions of devices uh we have Marquee
network security product uh in the web
security space uh ursphile blue code we
have caspi DLP secure access so we have
the complete portfolio of solution for
sassy and then ztna we also have a
payment security solution if you're
familiar with verified by Visa we
co-developed that and we continue to be
a leader in that space as well
now coming to our journey with Google
Cloud
we have had a very symbiotic
relationship with with Google
we were probably the first billion
dollar company that adopted G Suite we
still continue to use that and we our
foreign software kind of started with
the acquisition of brocade and that's
when first set of workloads we started
moving to gcp but uh things started
moving along the more traction with the
acquisition of CA Technologies that is
closely followed by semantic when we
decided that we'll move all the SAS
products into Google Cloud right and
this was not a simple lift and shift
exercise we use the opportunity
to transform them uh to be able to do
say like a 12 Factor app microservice
them containerize the applications and
run them in in kubernetes right so
we went through this transmission for
all these SAS Services
uh and uh we had shut down several data
centers in this process and this SAS
Journey was was a great transformative
one are we talking about our lab
migration in a little bit and the
assured workloads in a subsequent
session uh later this afternoon actually
now as I said like we run all of our SAS
Solutions almost all of our sales
Solutions inside Google so we have a
fairly large footprint we run in 39
regions today several tens of thousands
of VMS we are a very big gke shop the
stats go uh so on on and on right
because of our Global presence the
diverse set of customers we are always
secure we go through all the compliance
regimes like PCI DSS soft to fedramp
it's it's really important for us
because we hold a lot of customer data
I want to focus a little more on this
developed Cloud conscious culture so the
one that I talked about this Mega
transformation effort that we took to
migrate or re-transform all these SAS
services
to go through such an exercise there's
one critical thing that that we had to
do that is to empower the engineer right
so I mean the engineer needs to have the
right set of training resources the
right set of tooling and the visibility
into and into the environments with
which they operate and that helps them
give the ownership and the
accountability in terms of
uh big enough accountable to be to
optimize the environment and make it
more efficient right so this is a really
important part for again the large
transmission effort like what we
undertook it's really critical that the
engineer is at the center of this
now
you're done with this large
transformation effort
and even before we started sipping the
champagne we realized that we had a
problem right and more importantly we
had a bigger opportunity
while I think folks that that build
products will will relate to this one if
you have products both in the SAS and
on-prem space
SAS is typically the tip of the spear
and on-prem solutions kind of trail
behind right so we follow a kind of a
very similar approach where we moved all
our SAS into into the cloud whereas we
were still developing and testing our
on-prem Solutions our on-prem products
in the in the in the traditional way
running these labs in the in the in the
data centers
so we had like almost 165 plus unique
development and test labs and uh these
were running in various data centers all
over the world multiple office sites
the utilization was pretty low
height high TCL
the model was a was a capex model where
any kind of expansion took a lot of time
it was not easy for us to get anything
new right and also from a technology
perspective the infrastructure
perspective we had all kinds of all Hues
and shades of of infrastructure starting
from your small pizza boxes to all the
way to the best hyper conversion
infrastructure that's available
now
that was the that was the problem
statement
and uh you may have heard this uh
Insurance commercial I think it has a
very catchy jingle as well but the
tagline goes like this
you only pay for what you need I think
that pretty much
captured like where we want it to be
right from this state where we were in
we wanted to get into a state where we
could do on-demand provisioning
when we need what we need
to be able to start stop
scale and to be able to pay only for
that
if you want to improve our utilization
right and also have a platform that is
kind of uniform and consistent where we
don't have all of these vagaries of of
infrastructure right
that's when you took a call
that's a simple one saying that we are
moving all of these labs
Lock Stock and Barrel into Google Cloud
like any of the large transmission
efforts it met with a lot of resistance
that at start people are even
questioning like what are you smoking
right so it's illegal now in the State
uh so
it took us some time to get past those
barriers I think some of them uh we were
talking about environments where there
are hundreds of products
um again
over 2000 Engineers right that are
actively working with on these Labs
across all geographies time zones so it
was a
it was a gargant to an effort actually
so
the good part about it was we were able
to explain the end State the end state
was the engineer had a lot more control
on on the environments than what they
had now right the first the first
biggest point and there are no more
hidden costs you know no more costs that
are that you don't know okay you you
exactly know you that the emitter is
running and you know what you're paying
for
and the other important thing was around
the training aspect where we were able
to with the help of Google we were able
to get training for all of these
Engineers across the board so once they
became more familiar with the the latest
and greatest that the cloud offered so
it gave them the the confidence that
they will be able to leverage this right
and that kind of snowballed into
an acceptance and that's how the the
project started moving forward actually
so once the uh and our goal was to
migrate whatever machines we had into
GCE and
we were using migrate for computer
engine at that point in time uh I think
we also worked with Google on a
third-party solution because we had uh
hypervisors like ahp ESX and our private
Cloud was running in openstack so we had
to
we had to find a converter that was able
to convert all of these so we found a
tool things are moving quick things are
moving well that's what we thought did
we hit a brick wall right
so there was a problem where several of
our products were actually built
in the ESX vsphere ecosystem like the
entire automation the entire thing was
was built around that
we also had products that had to be
tested in this environment in the ESX
Casper environment
but more more importantly we
were running various flavors of
operating systems
because our just to mimic our customers
so these operating systems could not be
run in in GCE
whereas we had an easy option of getting
all of these things to run in GCV that's
how we evaluated dcv and we adopted gcde
at that stage for for that exact use
case so once we started using it
we found the interface very consistent
with what we are we're familiar with on
the on-prem side it's the exact same
interface
and as shinethany mentioned uh it's a
managed offering you don't have to worry
about infrastructure Google takes care
of the patching Google takes care of all
the upgrades things like that
and all the levers that we had on the
on-prem side in terms of cost we still
continue to have them right so so it
worked out of the box straight away okay
and uh I think as Manoj mentioned uh we
use hcx to migrate from our existing
VMware environment into GCV fairly
fairly easily
now today we have well over 100 nodes I
think we're talking about 110 now below
10 000 VMS which are running in GCV
several clusters we use this opportunity
as a good one like a spring cleaning
exercise to clean up the stuff that we
didn't need we migrated I wouldn't use
the word lift and shift we lifted and
transformed
and only what we needed right we right
size the environments to make sure that
because now we are in an environment
where you could provision what you want
okay you can start small and then scale
up as you need right so in this process
we Consolidated thousands of machines
and we were able to shut down five data
centers right
we were able to significantly bring down
our costs I already talked about our
overall approach in terms of being cloud
and cost conscious that's a culture that
we built ground up uh every engineering
engineer you you walk in broadcom it
will tell you like what their average
cost is right so that's the kind of
culture that we build based on the
visibility that one has right and
thousands of Engineers now had access to
the cloud okay it's not just gcbe
anymore they had access to things Beyond
VMware where they had access to things
like bigquery and the other services
that that the cloud offers right and
because we moved from a capex to an Opex
model it was much easier for us to spin
up and spin down when we need and the
deployments are now taking minutes right
instead of months weeks and months that
it used to happen before
and last but not the least uh we use we
realize Ops for our monitoring
alerting and it helped us immensely in
terms of optimizing our environment
oops
so the outcomes I already talked about
what we did for the developer at the end
of the day it was all about liberating
the developer right now they're not
worried about the nuances of am I going
to get my infrastructure am I going to
get this on time right so that got taken
away and uh it freed the the developer
to to things that they do best to build
world-class software right because the
constraints were removed it helped us to
accelerate the delivery and we also
created a community right where people
were sharing best practices people are
sharing scripts people who were
exchanging ideas discussing problems so
that Community helped us to get there
much faster
and last but not the least
we had a great partner in Google with
that helped us thick and thin during
this journey without which this is not
possible and a shout out to my team my
extended broadcom team that made this
huge Mammoth transmission possible thank
you everyone thank you
[Applause]
thank you Ganesh
I think you know to get a partner of
this scale to get a customer of the
scale and to be able to see this kind of
Journey that changes so many lives is
just tremendous fear we're truly blessed
and I think uh you know I think I really
appreciate the cloud conscious culture
that you talked about and how you helped
build that in your in your context so
it's truly phenomenal and I think along
the same lines I want to say that this
service and these capabilities building
the making the best of VMware and Google
would not have been possible without the
partnership with VMware and I think uh
for that I want to get a message from
VMware uh in this session as well for us
to all hear before we close
hello I'm Krish Prasad I'm the general
manager of the cloud infrastructure
business group in VMware very excited to
be here Google cloud and VMware has had
a very close and deep partnership for
many years it was just three years ago
that we jointly launched Google Cloud
VMware engine since then we have seen a
huge momentum amongst our customers to
adopt this cloud and it is now without
question one of the top performing
clouds that VMware customers go to
customers really love uh the ability to
seamlessly move their applications uh
from their data centers uh to gcve
because they don't have to think about
retraining their people they don't have
to change their processes and tools and
they also can take advantage of some of
the Native services that Google offers
as an example in the AIML space that
allows our customers to then accelerate
their digital transformation journey and
so all of this has resulted in a huge
momentum for this service across many
Industries and I'm very confident that
Google Cloud VMware engine will be one
of the top destinations for our
customers for years to come thank you
very much
all right so with that we'll close I
think we just have a minute left we'll
be available here for questions outside
for questions I know we didn't get
enough time to do that but thank you all
and uh thank you for coming and I hope
you enjoyed the session